from cnr.com doj will not seek criminal
charges against Biden due to his mental
limitations it could be it would be
difficult to convince a jury that they
should convict him of a serious felony
that requires a mental state of
willfulness holy crap they are saying
that Biden
is so old and broken he does not have
his own force of will anymore or at the
very least to be fair you could not
convince a reasonable person that Biden
has a mental state of
willfulness I'm thinking about rean I
think they did this with rean do you
remember Ronald Reagan being like I've
got Alzheimer's and they're like okay
then you can't punish him for all the
war crimes he did or whatever he did in
the 80s he's like yeah I don't even
remember and they're like all right you
think Reagan was acting I think that
maybe they played the Alzheimer's thing
up to get out of like some of the some
of the stuff he done I that I I've heard
that that was us it like get stuff in
the in the into into the like law
actually if if if Biden cannot be held
accountable because of his diminished
mental state he cannot be president no
you're right so I did see a tweet from
Jack bov and he was like because of the
uh uh the the class because of the
classified documents we may not get a
prosecution but we may get the 25th
Amendment yeah right and and that's
where we could remove Joe Biden for B
and then why I don't know kamla Harris I
guess and they were talking about the
25th Amendment at the end of trump and
people were like they're using it for
Trump but they were setting this up no
no like when they announced the uh 25th
amendment panel was being created
which the 25th Amendment says like you
can basically remove an incapacitated
president so they're going to create
this committee and then vote out in
Congress that would have the ability to
make the determination if the president
was mentally unfit everyone's like
they're going to do this to get rid of
trump and then within like 10 minutes
everyone's like actually they're doing
this to get rid of B Democrats are
setting this up to get rid of Biden yeah
what was the lawsuit they were trying to
push forward that they said they can't
no this is criminal charges he will not
be criminally prosecuted for the crimes
he committed let me read in the report
it says in his interview with our office
Mr Biden's memory was worse he did not
remember when he was vice president
forgetting on the first day of the
interview when his term ended if it was
2013 when did I stop being vice
president and forgetting on the second
day of the interview when his term began
in 2009 am I still vice president he did
not remember even within several years
when his son Bo died and his memory
appeared hazy when describing the
Afghanistan debate that was once so
important to him among other things he
mistakenly said he had a real difference
of opinion with General Carl ikenberry
when in fact ikenberry was an ally who
Mr Biden cited approvingly in his
Thanksgiving memo to President
Obama this is the doj being like uh this
guy has no force of will like there's
he's he's gone I thought you were going
to say ikenberry was a cartoon character
that Biden used to watch in the
50 ien Barry was the character on the on
the lots of Berry cereal box think going
to make to the end of the term no really
you don't think so I don't what do you
think is going to happen I don't know I
don't there could be many things I did
say this back in like November I did a
segment where I was looking at all the
news and I was like Biden will be out he
will be out some way I I have to say
like right now it's hard to believe
because it's February and we're so close
to the
election I think a reasonable conclusion
is man if if if if it came down to it
and I had to put 10 bucks on he's in or
he's out he's out I think they're going
to have him do some type of sympathetic
step down where he's going to be like
this this corpse figure giving a speech
being I can't do this anymore it's for
the better of the country and they're
going to do that to make him yeah like
sympathetic to people well he won't make
it through that speech but he won't
you're right they'll need AI be every
speech he has a gap yes like there isn't
a normal one he's speaking right now
apparently as well oh we should watch
should we pull it up I heard he was
going live at like 7:45 yeah he did like
some unscheduled speech maybe he's
talking about Putin I don't know I just
seen the chat people send he speaking
live right now so I mean I I don't know
if I care all that I don't I just love
that the people who who thought Koff was
like Trump being mentally deranged okay
with this second one by providing
ammunition and material for them to
defend themselves W he is alive
coincidentally yeah I think he's talking
about Ukraine that's the time frame when
this broke out I have no proof what I'm
about to say but it's not unreasonable
to suspect that the Hamas understood
what was about to take place and break
it up before it happen
hey good timing on our part he just
walks off did a hand just emerge to tell
him to come this way did you guys see
the uh I think so what the
coincidentally did you guys see the
interview he was doing time frame with
this where the reporter goes off script
and immediately his hand is like Mr B Mr
Biden and he's like no I'm going to do
this anyway oh yeah it was about to take
place and wanted to break it up before
it
happened
I think he's remote controlled dude
there's a hand there a camera I wish it
was a movie or something to laugh at or
is it a remote control I guess there is
a hand on the camera what if that is the
hand of the real when's the last time he
took questions like full-blown press
confer never never yeah they've always y
he's skipping the Super Bowl interview
which is like a big deal yeah I guess
the second time he's refused to do an
interview like the president does a
Super Bowl interview it's like the a big
moment in the country really Trump's
like I'll do it and they're you know
they're not going to do it Trump
you know I'm I I think it's important
for history's sake that everyone
remember this moment where you were a
moment you'll never forget when the doj
said Joe Biden's mental state had
diminished to the point of no longer
being a willful human being that is to
say this is the day when it was
determined by our executive branch the
president was no longer a sentient human
being this the thing if someone Comm
commits like a crime but they're not
mentally aware you put them in a mental
institution you don't put them in the
jail necessarily take them to a hospital
because they weren't mentally prepared
or me mentally cognizant I I have a
story for you guys it's a story that
I've told maybe twice on this show when
I was about 14 in uh my neighborhood on
the south side of Chicago there was a
rumor don't know the exact details or
how it went down but this is the story
that we were told when we were children
that a girl our age had been crossing
the street when an elderly man blew the
stop sign running her over she was
crossing in a crosswalk with a stop sign
as an oldmobile was coming up and she
didn't think it mattered because the car
would stop but it didn't and it ran her
over it was a very old man who was
driving and when he hit her he stopped
instantly she was now underneath his car
not knowing what he hit he put it in
reverse backing up crushing her head
like a melon splattering it that's we
were told killing her and that if he had
not moved she would have lived the
penalty for this was they revoked his
license I mean what are you going to do
it was an older
man I mean apparently he was in his 70s
or something and is is did he commit a
crime or is he just incapacitated at
this point he should no longer Drive due
to his diminished mental state so they
determined based on this we will remove
his license now I don't know the full
details I'm sure the story was not 100%
% that way that's just what we were all
hearing and everyone was saying cuz like
a girl our age like went to school at
the same time I don't know who she was
died but it was like friends of friends
do we want to wait for that moment with
Joe Biden no not for the commander of
the military when he presses the button
and then when a city like Moscow is
wiped out and we're facing down the
barrel of all of Russia's icbms everyone
just says maybe we should impeach him
now the thing is the American people
have not been privy to to a a real
military loss in my lifetime they don't
understand what it means if your
commander slips up whether intentionally
or unintentionally and causes the death
of women your your wife your wife and
your children and your families and your
city is burned to the ground because of
some mistake that the immediately he's
removed from Power immediately whether
it's the president the lead the general
in charge they're stripped of command if
they do that well people yeah not to
make you guys uh think any worse of the
guy but apparently he walked off when we
were watching him and then he walked
back out and then he said that BB was
the president of Mexico so wait what no
almost don't believe
you you may not believe me but that's
what I'm getting from chat that's what
he said so and you guys don't believe me
about Joe
bid W here we go I I don't believe he
walked back out that's that's what I've
been told I mean the stream shut down is
there some other video on something no I
don't know that's it was that the second
time he walked off that's I don't know
if there's if there's the first one they
said that he walked off and came back at
some point he walked off after repor
question him then he comes back
reporters grilled him about his AG's
memory apparently that's what he took
questions so well I suppose we'll have
to try and find that on X or something
yeah I don't know maybe it's it's
elsewhere but that's what I was told so
he won't be charged in classified
documents case because he has poor
memory oh my god well I don't think he
should be charged in that stupid case
anyway but not because of poor memory
just because why would you charge a an
ex vice president for accidentally or
for even intentionally maybe so so we
have this let's uh let's play the clip
from Newsmax so I don't know if he came
back out here we go something the
special counsel said in his report is
that one of the reasons you were not
charged is because in his description
you are a well-meaning elderly man with
a poor
memory I'm an elderly man and I know
what the hell I'm doing I've been
president I put this country back on his
feet I don't need his recommendation
that's totally out his lawyer is going
stop shut up stop is your memory and can
you continue as president
my memory is so bad I let you speak what
that's that's your memory has
gotten no that's right though that's Dey
don't give it he's going to get you if
you remembered this you wouldn't let him
speak m is not my memory is fine my
memory take a look at what I've done
since I become president none of you
thought I could pass any of the things I
got passed how'd that happen you know I
guess I just forgot what was going on oh
there there at least he took a question
no no listen listen like do a sarc right
now his lawyers are face palming like
the doj just let you walk you went on
television said no I'm fine he literally
says the doj says they're not going to
prosecute you because your memory is no
good no my memory is fine you're you
literally just said prosecute me yep
right I think they're weaning him off
all the uppers so he can melt into a
pile of skin before they like sweep him
off the stage and then let KLA come in I
when they're like your memor is I hear
your memories bad and he's like yeah my
memory is so bad he's doing the sarcasm
thing which is just indicating that he
does believe he has a bad memory I need
to fact check Serge he didn't say that
um Benjamin Netanyahu was the president
of Mexico he said Egyptian president
Abdul fata Eli allegedly was president
of mexic I apologize thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time